welcome back to new rockstars this is
bite size questions that philip will
answer for us they're in the box let's
do this
well you can get the box too take it
away
pizza time when tony collapses an end
game near the beginning captain marvel
says she's gonna pick up some sort of
elixir
what was that you guys take care of him
and i'll bring a bizarre and elixir when
i come back yeah it seems like a quick
throw away yeah
yeah she's a great actress
get back in your room room child roots
child these are gonna get elixir
um she is referring to basically chicken
soup
but it's kind of the equivalent uh but
it is cool if you do follow the the idea
of the zorians
what she actually is referring to is
this race that
theoretically remember uh in the aliens
movies how
eventually it's kind of revealed that
maybe the precursor to like humans
kind of aliens like it got really
complicated there is a marvel version of
that and it's that the zorians
actually were the initial basis for
what eventually would become humans cree
scrolls oh any any of these like main
humanoid figures that we we interact
with a lot
are actually just them experimenting
with their own dna and then eventually
that evolves into the rest of us so
the zorians have theoretically these
pharmaceutical abilities that can cure
things for any of us
on a dna level but it you know kind of
is a panacea that like maybe
it's a cure uh it's complicated if you
try to get into too much because it's
like
oh can you just bring that back in like
you're cancer yeah why is it carol
danvers doing that
all the time like it's pricey yeah get
back in your room
room she sucks thor defeated certain
easily but couldn't even hurt hella
while searcher defeated hella easily
how is that possible what am i missing
in here tell me if you do watch
if you do watch ragnarok kind of quickly
it is like wait the bad guy
that he beat up at the beginning is the
destroyer
of all of ragnarok at the end and is the
prophesied one and hell is the villain
of the whole movie and this
thing can defeat hella pretty power
statuses are shifting action it does
change but it actually is totally
covered in the movie
a really easy way to see it too is you
can see at the beginning
that sorter is only like three times
bigger than chris hemsworth at the
in the early part so chris hemsworth is
the same as me six three
and then if you multiply that by three
or so he's maybe about 19 feet or
something
so he's like not short but he ain't that
big look at him at the end of the movie
he's like a giant
he's the size of a city he's a colossal
um so you can
both combine that the idea that of
course if he's bigger he's more
destructive but he also has higher
durability
increased strength all these things so
he's like insane to try to defeat
in that scenario but it's specifically
because
if you remember in the movie odin had
taken his power source away the eternal
flame
right before and this is the version of
searcher that has gotten the eternal
flame
back so now this is what he's actually
like and he's
actually one of the strongest figures in
all of marvel so wow that does make
sense that he actually can defeat
hella and he's the prophesied one to
destroy so it's the idea the internal
flame wasn't there and now it's back and
that's why you can
basically he's been bulking got it thank
you to skillshare for sponsoring this
video
skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of inspiring
classes for creative and curious people
explore new skills deepen existing
passions and get lost in creativity
skillshare offers classes designed for
real life you can learn and grow with
short classes that fit
any schedule in this new year resolve to
learn a new skill
increase your capacity to work through
this difficult world they have classes
and topics new rockstars fans will enjoy
like animation
film music production class i'm really
excited to check out is narrative art
drawing imaginary characters taught by
graphic novelist ira marx
the class focuses on how to imagine and
design the kinds of characters that draw
us
in and lead us on their crazy adventures
no matter what 2021 brings you spend it
creating something meaningful with
skillshare's online classes
skillshare is curated specifically for
learning but there are no ads and they
are always launching new premium classes
so that you can stay focused and follow
wherever your creativity takes you
and it's less than ten dollars a month
with an annual subscription the first
1000 people to use the link in the
description will get a free trial of
skillshare premium membership so that
you can explore your creativity
all right so uh our final bite size
question ooh
uh so we actually asked our discord fans
yes what
marvel villain would make the best
president so this was a question from
us to our discord uh patrons and fans on
there and then i'm just gonna read some
uh
fun answers that we got on there so a
lot of people thought doctor doom would
make a really good
oh sure yeah he's brilliant um pointed
out he already rules a country so he has
that
experience he is brilliant he's adored
in the country that he rules but a lot
of people
uh also were like that's too easy
because he already rules the country so
they talk about green goblin
which green goblin actually i think in
in a specific story has become president
and i remember like
when i was like in middle school or
something right he was all the villains
were becoming president at the time
likes luther and stuff too
uh i like this person didn't understand
the question perfectly so
so the question was which marvel villain
would make the best president
and he said t'challa which is black
panther and then
we said we said villains and they said
oh
evil t'challa which is great there was
talk about thanos actually had some good
ideas but he would institute a purge
almost immediately yeah thanos did
nothing wrong
this was my favorite answer was wilson
fisk oh yeah um he
is a man of the people but he's a
billionaire and those never mislead us
but they're also he becomes the mayor of
new york in a daredevil company i don't
know something about the mcu wilson fisk
too that guy like
i could vote for that yeah appreciates
art
right he's a man of the arts and isn't
afraid to get his hands dirty
yeah with a car door right um and this
was
maybe my favorite answer that i don't
agree with but but it's my favorite
answer
is somebody pointed out well star wars
comics are now published by marvel
okay so palpatine is technically a
villain
uh and so they think palpatine would be
the best president what i was thinking
about that was
you never really hear about palpatine's
platform
like he could have great ideas what if
he's like instituting
a galaxy basic income yeah i mean like
he could be
like really helping a lot of people i
mean isn't his ideas just what the nazi
ideas were just like
he doesn't do do like uh genocide
execute
order 66. huh
he does aggressive force with you he
does he killed all the geonosians
oh and he also blows up planets he
sterilized their race the most epic
level of genocide that's ever happened
palpatine hasn't killed anyone he kills
planets we don't know if anybody's on
them he's just not checking these are
his minions he's like i don't like that
point obi-wan said i just heard millions
of voices scream out in terror and
that's obi-wan's problem
he was trying to and there was a planet
in the way and he was going to create a
bunch of jobs
anyway i do think that it's worth noting
palpatine was elected a senator at one
point
so at some point he gave good speeches
and had a good platform well yeah he was
elected chancellor too
exactly so as
hitler was elected too don't bring him
into this
every week he's always in it well that's
our show guys remind her to send us your
big questions using the hashtag
big question also no i'm not going for a
high five but i'm giving a high five
to uh danny who sent us some uh dope ass
fan art on twitter and on our discord uh
we love fan art here's his fan art
fan art so send them to our p.o box you
can send them
legit or you can send questions you can
send anything to our po box as long as
it
can go in the mail but almost anything
can go into that yeah subscribe to this
show here
on youtube but also subscribe to the
podcast version so you can get audio
versions of all this stuff so you can
listen to all your driving and not have
to like watch
youtube video while you're driving
because follow phillip at philip molina
follow me at ea boss and follow me
rockstars
on twitter and on instagram so you can
keep up with all of our stuff and uh
remember uh to check in with us next
week because we'll have a whole new big
question for you
responsibly
[Music]
you